[Musique]
oui on a vu les on a vu les squelettes
et je pense un peu la principale chose
pour laquelle on est venu tous et puis
non on a pris plein de choses bah les
archéologues la nous expliquer oui euh
si on avait des questions ils ont
répondu à toutes nos questions j'ai
envie d'être
[Musique]
AR on a commencé le décapage
c'est-à-dire à ouvrir le terrain à
enlever tous les niveaux supérieurs en
fin septembre donc sur une surface
d'environ 600 m² 650 m² on a réussi à
trouver assez rapidement à 1 m de
profondeur les premières sépultures donc
les squelette hein tout ce qui formait
le cimetière paroissal de l'ancienne
église Saint-Maclou donc du Moyen-Âge
puis on a réussi à continuer et à
trouver tout l'ensemble de l'ulion
urbain
[Musique]
pour l'instant ce que j'ai pu constater
c'est qu'effectivement j'ai une habitude
d'Imation plutôt ancienne puisque j'ai
l'impression d'avoir plutôt des fausses
avec des couvercles des contenants sans
clou et quelques empierrements donc
c'est plutôt ancien ce qui
correspondrait effectivement à cette
période plutôt du 13e
siècle après il va falloir attendre
l'étude ensuite en poste fouille donc
après lavage des
eau
nous sommes des archéologue du préventif
donc c'est une habitude nous n'avons pas
du tout le même temps de par rapport à à
tous nos collègues de université ou du
CNRS euh nous euh
nous avons cette mission qui est
effectivement de de finalement préserver
avant les travaux avant la destruction
ce qui est complètement différent de
mission par exemple sur des fouilles
programmées sur de long cours à
l'étranger où les enjeux ne sont pas du
tout les mêmes en
fait il y a besoin de fouiller
préalablement à la réalisation de ces
travaux pour être s de de pas détruire
les vestiges et d'avoir une connaissance
précise de des sous-sols de M la jolie
et de son
[Musique]
histoire toute feu archéologique va
entraîner forcément des surcous des
délais par rapport au travaux qu'on en
visage mais on a la chance ici à manth
comme d'autres villes ailleurs d'avoir
une
une histoire longue derrière nous dont
on est héritier et
passeur parce
fait merci
beaucoup